hello i'm justin and i'm jeremy and we
both teach at the institute of design at
stanford university which we call the
d-school stanford has been fortunate to
be at the cutting edge of the
intersection of art and engineering
design thinking is a methodology that
has come out of that intersection but
more than a simple process it's a way of
being and acting and interacting
increasingly the problems that are
facing our governments and organizations
and industries aren't problems that fit
neatly within any one area of
disciplinary expertise leveraging design
thinking teams from radically diverse
backgrounds can work together and
amplify their respective contributions
to the problems that we now face
our aim is not merely to build up frothy
enthusiasm and excitement but rather to
give you some of the core dna that's
required to make a meaningful cultural
transformation because design thinking
gives us tools and frameworks to help us
focus on how human behavior is adapting
to those changes it allows us to look at
those changes optimistically throughout
this program you'll be hearing examples
of how individuals and other
organizations have used different
aspects of design thinking to achieve
wonderful outputs
there's what you get as an individual
what do you learn about your creativity
and how do you inspire creativity in the
people around you
there's the tools and practices of
design thinking itself how do we create
teams that understand each other that
have a common language and then there's
the institutional impact what might it
mean for your organization if
individuals feel this way if teams work
in this way and it replicates out all of
those things will have a different level
of impact for each of you in this
program
design thinking is designed to help you
be adaptable in the face of this
changing environment so that you
continue to be relevant and you continue
to be fulfilled and enriched in the work
that you're doing and the impact you're
making on the world
[Music]